la cantidad de lluvia que cae en varias
ciudades de francia varía la gráfica de
puntos abajo muestra la precipitación
promedio mensual en 13 ciudades
distintas
las medidas están redondeadas al cuarto
el centímetro más cercano cuánta lluvia
más cae en la ciudad más lluviosa que en
la segunda ciudad más lluviosa veamos y
entendemos lo que ellos llaman la
gráfica de puntos que tenemos aquí cada
uno de estos puntos representa una de
las ciudades cuya precipitación promedio
mensual fue medida así por ejemplo este
punto de aquí representa la única ciudad
cuya precipitación promedio mensual fue
de 6 centímetros por otro lado estos dos
puntos que tenemos aquí representan a
dos ciudades cuya precipitación promedio
mensual fue veamos ocho y tres cuartos
centímetros hay dos ciudades que
tuvieron una precipitación promedio
mensual de 12 y 34 centímetros así es
que esta gráfica nos indica para un
valor dado de precipitación cuántas
ciudades tuvieron esa cantidad de lluvia
en promedio mensual así es
ahora que ya sabemos lo que representa
esta gráfica tratemos de responder lo
que nos preguntan cuánta lluvia más cae
en la ciudad más lluviosa la ciudad más
lluviosa es esta de aquí hay una sola
ciudad más lluviosa y que tiene un
promedio mensual de precipitación de 13
y un medio centímetros pongámoslo aquí
la precipitación promedio esta ciudad es
3 y un medio centímetros cuánta lluvia
más cae en la ciudad más lluviosa que en
la segunda ciudad más lluviosa que en la
segunda ciudad más lluviosa que se
estará acá con una precipitación de 13 y
14 centímetros de promedio mensual así
es que la diferencia entre estas dos es
este pedazo este pedazo que va de 13 y
14 centímetros a 13 y un medio
centímetros vemos que entre cada
centímetro hay cuatro pedazos así es que
este pedazo va a medir un cuarto de
centímetro así es que basados en esa
apreciación visual podemos concluir que
la diferencia es un cuarto de centímetro
un cuarto de centímetro ahora si no
fuera tan claro pues aquí coincidió que
estaban sobre las marcas precisas
entonces podemos restar
al valor mayor el valor menor es decir
vamos a restar tres enteros un medio
menos tres enteros un cuarto y hay
muchas maneras de hacer esto primero
podría restar 13 de 13 para
posteriormente restar en un cuarto de un
medio y así obtener en un cuarto pero
nosotros vamos a convertir estos números
a fracciones impropias aquí tenemos 13 y
un medio esto es 2 por 13 26 y 1 2727
medios menos menos 13 y 14 es 13 por 4
52 y 153 sería entonces 27 medios menos
53 cuartos y para hacer esta resta
tenemos que encontrar el común
denominador común denominador entre 4 y
24 es múltiplo de 2 744 entre 2 a 2 por
27 esto es 54 cuartos menos 54 cuartos
menos 53 cuartos
es igual a esto es igual a 54 menos 53 1
sobre 4 un cuarto de centímetro y esto
que hicimos aquí fue un poco redundante
pero es lo que tenías que hacer si no
estuvieran en marcas precisas y
contiguas estos valores